well all i can say is congratulations
cancel podcast three episodes in number
one on itunes and you haven't been sued
yet oh my god okay but i swear to god we
are this close from being sued
cancer don't remember doing this at all
i can only hold myself accountable
look how good my life is so what else
cancer means i think although to be so
successful though so many people are
listening i never thought anyone would
ask that question i think everything i
do is
you're like is this a forbes interview
no no but that's that question within
itself is crazy because it's like i
didn't i don't know i
i didn't think this would happen this
way i didn't i didn't think it would top
the charts right away i definitely
thought it was something we would have
to climb up and like work for and the
fact that to be honest with you like
obviously over time like we hope to get
better and better but like i that's the
fans like the fans were
right there streaming it before they
even knew if they liked it or not
episode one and like i wouldn't have it
like if it wasn't for them i know it's
such a like cheesy thing to say but like
they're loyal my fan
the best ever i can't even believe it it
makes me want to cry even thinking about
it it's amazing it's a crowded market
there are a lot of podcasts out there
what was the inspiration like why did
you want to do cancelled and why call it
canceled to be honest with you we had a
lot of thoughts as to what the name
should be we went back and forth on the
name for like longer than i've really
debated a lot of things in my career
but
everything that we say has a borderline
chance of getting us cancelled yeah and
it was like that was also a big fear
with the podcast it was like you're
gonna let me sit down and talk for an
hour like i'm gonna ruin my whole life
you're like am i about to be canceled i
remember my relationship my brand deals
my everything like i'm gonna pick up
everything so i think that canceled is
it's such a blanket statement it
encompasses it all so perfectly so it's
like
we i don't know when we thought of it we
thought about it for a while but
eventually it was like why would we call
it anything else also i feel like it's
such a reflection of the times with this
canceled culture you're almost poking
fun at it you're like i dare you to do
it i mean it's gonna happen either way
you know and like our guests obviously
too i gravitate towards crazy people
yeah that are i mean our first two
guests were trisha paytas and bryce hall
like you couldn't be more canceled than
that so it's like so you're going
forward excited exactly and to talk
about even like upcoming we have like
paris hilton like she's not the most
canceled but to talk to her about the
way cancelled culture has affected her
and her life for the last like you know
what i mean decade or two is uh you know
it just for sure it's very interesting i
think it's something that people looked
at as taboo for so long it's almost like
you're creating a safe space for these
stars who are like always borderline
like am i gonna cancel that's gonna be
my new thing is cancelled therapy but
you really do go there and obviously
three episodes and there's already been
so much tea yeah there's always been so
much tea so let's get right into it
starting with oh you're asking about tea
is that it doesn't it's really fun it's
your new house that you're renting from
david
[Music]
of
dobrik
david failed to mention the entire zoo
that comes along with the house the
gophers the moles the rats the size of
chihuahuas cockroach cockroaches
as you said there is a list of issues
with it but you still want to rent it oh
my god well to be fair love you to death
daddy david i didn't know about a lot of
issues well to be fair i don't think
david knew like david david is so
rich i think that he's like you're in my
little house over there like i don't
know like he literally doesn't think
about it it's like filled with it he
like doesn't care if he gets it back
whatever we were in a really weird
situation moving-wise where i kept
wanting houses and i have really bad
luck so things just kept going wrong and
eventually was the point where i needed
to get out of my house and i literally
was like hey david i might want to buy
your house i want to try it out and it's
cool to have a
rich ass friend who lets you take their
house for a spin
[Music]
after living there i don't i don't know
i don't know so you're still debating
whether you're going to purchase it or
not yeah and i'm i'm leaning i'm leaning
more towards no i'm not going to lie
there's a lot i love david's to death
but i think giving it back to him might
be
solution you know what it's good to be
uh there while you're looking for the
other people yeah exactly exactly and
it's the memories that were there are
like so beautiful so getting to like
live there is it's just iconic it's
crazy those walls could talk a bit then
there were two i know you know what
nobody likes us the two [ __ ] are left
you just mentioned that episode trisha
which was instantly iconic you know
obviously she opened up about frenemies
ending which is something you were sad
about but isn't it i love that i mean
everyone did it
icon i just i love i love crazy but i
love listening to crazy
and it was just the most insane podcast
ever now be honest though do you feel
like okay now there's a spot for
cancelled though we could fill in the
dude the friend of me i'm not gonna lie
to you the internet it was like the the
ocean's partying for me you know what i
mean because i i would no it's not
computable i think it was like one of my
favorite podcasts of all time even when
i look at this one i'm like it is it is
nothing in comparison about it trish is
an icon you know what i mean i thought
long and hard about we had a list of so
many first guest ideas and then i was
like i woke up one day and i was like
it's trisha the caller and then she said
yes i thought she was gonna say no i did
not think she'd say yes so that was cool
well i don't put any words in your mouth
but is it safe to assume that you're a
team trisha versus team ethan no um
definitely i mean to be fair i also am
not
i'm not like a team-oriented individual
because it's like who am i to be telling
people who is right is wrong like i just
like to watch and obviously everyone
loves some drama like i watched every
drama channel video on i don't know
ethan personally and i really don't know
the
details of the situation well enough to
like know what happened it was more so
that i was like mourning frenemies and
just like bawling my eyes out the
podcast is over i i don't know no ethan
seems like a great person as well so let
me ask you about some other drama
because it came up during the trish
episode gabby versus escape the night oh
yeah i mean what do you mean i like the
sweat on my brow well what do you think
of it since you were in the show yeah i
got a call from
that should i say it i think that gabby
hannah was trying to sell to them
that this youtuber like hooked up with
me when i was like underage i liked a
joey graceffa tweet about what you know
like you know just impertinence to like
his video or whatever yeah and then i
get this call
gabby hannah called me and said this
youtuber trying to hook up with you when
you were live
i didn't even think about the fact i was
like damn well now that i'm thinking
about it i guess that could be something
that could be but it's mine to like have
or not you cannot bring someone else's
trauma public like if you've never
talked about it if you're friends with
this person like regardless of how like
wrong
no okay no ill like i'm sorry there are
like there's like
i don't know that's like the one person
like i actually think is like a vile
it's a really interesting experience
the truth
comes out in in a lot of crazy ways and
i it's hard because
trisha and i spoke on this you spend a
lot of time uh afraid of someone kind of
coming back for you so you don't say
things you know what i mean yeah and you
run into these people and a lot of
people a lot of people with power and
power in this industry will
you know
evoke fear and a lot of other people but
i i think joey and daniel are really
good people and i'm not going to sit
here and act like the escape the night
was hell because of her was still one of
the best experiences ever but there were
definitely some tense insane moments on
set and seeing them finally come to
fruition on the forefront of the
internet like publicly is
same thing with the trisha and ethan
thing it's just interesting to watch
it's interesting to see laugh at yeah
you know i don't know joey he told i i
was kind of warned about that drama
before it came out but i knew it was
coming you know what i mean yeah so i
was when it came out i was kind of just
like well you know you know sometimes
you gotta just
sometimes you just hear the ticking
clock
sincerely sincerely
and i mean but bad things happen and i
can't sit here and act all high and
mighty like i haven't ever been a brat
in this life on a you know not like that
though no
throw myself under the bus like that uh
there's headlines there's drama it's
like you're used to you know that world
no yeah but i mean yeah i i'm not i'm
not perfect so i'm not here to sit and
act like i wasn't late to the first
season every day like you know what i
mean but
uh it is crazy
and you know it comes out eventually
also goes away
and this industry is filled with a lot
of people who are all very different and
everyone's a lot of people are going to
butt heads and you know i woke up one
day and realized i'm not going to be
able to be best friends with everyone
and that's just who i am and that's okay
like you know funny you should say that
because i'm going to move on to khloe
kardashian oh oh my god you did
apologize you wanted me best not to
learn babe i'm an idiot no is how you
feel i love chloe i think she's a
icon she is so funny she's gone through
so much and she's so ridiculously strong
i have a habit of twitter fingers let's
be real i see something happen and i
[ __ ] tweet it and
sometimes it comes back to bite me in
the house and
the news broke that tristan and chloe
split and then i was like oh tana mojo
entered the chat
oh lord um i'm sorry
i'm just in a silly goofy mood i really
was just perplexed as to why he was at
my party but i should have definitely
phrased it differently like they were
you know true was doing just fine she's
an adorable little angel like tana i
obviously i was trying to make a joke
about it being father's day and we
already discussed this on the podcast
but the joke did not hit that was
definitely a cancelled miss on my behalf
i formally apologize to chloe a lot
chloe if you're watching this you're not
but i'm sorry yeah there you have it
she's the best so you haven't heard from
her since babe i don't think i'll
be
so you're not getting invited to chris
jenner's christmas eve oh my god don't
say that i'm heartbroken no but i'm
definitely not so
that's you know no no no but i'm not
let's be real all right uh so yeah any
dream guest
for the podcast any dream guest for the
podcast i have one for you can i pitch
her yeah i think britney spears should
do the sit down right here oh my god
imagine i break that she's i'm pretty
sure she'll be fine with like dateline
or like abc or something when she wants
to talk about it i'm just saying this
could be a good for you brit that's a
crazy dream because people won't expect
it and not only will you keep it real
with her i feel like you'll make her
feel safe i would i would die for her no
question asked i would do anything in
the world where i hope she knows that
for you if you're watching this i love
you so much i just want you to win you
were the best
no yeah i don't know i don't know
everyone keeps asking me i keep jokingly
saying obama but i i really don't know i
don't know i just
the dream guest to me are just whoever's
gonna make a great episode i know that's
such a corny answer i need to think
about it more i think it'd be fun
eventually to maybe have like an x on or
someone i had beef with or you know what
i mean like a feud like that that would
be crazy crazier than and interviewing
anyone
you